l'indre et loire compte 8000 malades
d'alzheimer dans la panoplie des outils
de prise en charge les médicaments bien
sûr mais aussi le sport à tour la ligue
de tennis de table lance un programme de
sport santé à destination de ces publics
fragiles le sourire retrouvé le temps de
séances d'initiation voyez ce reportage
d'hélène chapelet à tour avant tout
effort physique il faut d'abord
s'échauffer
aujourd'hui c'est un public de seniors
qui s'apprête à découvrir le tennis de
table des personnes atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer et qui vont
désormais être accueillis tous les
mardis après-midi au sein du club de la
4s à tour richard à 80 ans il fait
partie de ceux qui se sont engagés à
venir jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
c'est son épouse qui a eu cette idée
pour avoir notamment un petit moment de
répit dans la journée il s'ennuie il a
pas d'activité il peut plus lire parce
qu'il se rappelle plus de ce qu'ils
nient donc j'avais entendu parler de ça
je trouve que c'est une bonne chose de
faire et puis il rencontre d'autres
personnes aussi
c'est ça qui est important c'est de
rencontrer d'autres messieurs de
discuter parce qu'il est tout le temps
avec moi vous reconnais toujours que
tous les deux quelques minutes après la
fin des exercices après un bref rappel
sur les conditions d'inscription par
aurore l'éducatrice sportive
professionnelle du club
la maladie a repris le dessus et richard
ne sait déjà plus pourquoi il est là je
suis vu ma femme que
les copines jouer là bas
le club tourangeau est le troisième de
france à proposer cette discipline sur
prescription médicale uniquement grâce
aux exercices proposés les participants
travaillent également l' équilibre et se
concentre sur une tâche à effectuer
on essaie voilà pendant 1h15 d'une heure
et demie de donner du bonheur et du
sport à ces personnes faut pas oublier
qu'ils viennent ici pour prendre du
plaisir nous moi mon objectif principal
c'est leur mieux sourire donc si on les
met en situation d'échec lors des
exercices c'est pas le but ce créneau
réservé aux personnes atteintes par la
maladie d'alzheimer sera reconduit
durablement à la rentrée et 10 à 12
personnes de 60 ans et plus seront alors
accueillies chaque semaine